President Trump goes to the UN and
smacks Rocketman plus was president
Trump indeed wiretap because there's new
news suggesting his campaign manager
certainly was and will talk about
Obamacare repeal which is back on this
table I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show so now I have Rocketman
stuck in my head as does everyone in the
United States because President Trump
decided to drop that reference during
his UN speech today we will play it for
you
President Trump went to the UN he gave
what I thought was the best speech of
his relatively young presidency that was
quite a good speech we'll go through
what was in it and what it shows about
American foreign policy because it does
sort of lend credence to the idea that
all this talk about realism versus
neo-cons that a lot of these gaps are a
little bit exaggerated but I'll explain
what I mean by all of that because now
I've got Rocketman stuck at me okay
we'll get into all of that but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over a bowl and branch so as I say one
of the things I love best in life is
that you don't actually in the United
States it's great you don't actually
have to be wealthy in order to live like
a wealthy person well one of the things
that makes you feel wealthy is climbing
into a set of sheets at night that is
just a top quality and you can do that
with bull and branch there are three ex
presidents who sleep on these sheets
plus me so lots of great people sleep on
these sheets and these are there's a
reason for it they are 100% organic
cotton and they're breathable
they're super comfortable much more
comfortable than whatever you are
sleeping on right now I know because I
got rid of all these sheets we own and
bought several pairs and Bull and bran
sheets after being spoiled by sleeping
on them right now they sell online
exclusively obviously and that means
that they sell for half the price and
twice the quality and if you try them
for 30 nights and you don't like it you
can return them for a full refund so it
really is a no-risk proposition go to
bull and branch comm today that's bol
Ella and branch comm today you get $50
off your first set of sheets plus free
shipping when you use promo code Ben 50
bucks off plus free shipping right now
at bull and branch calm and use that
promo Claire bennigan that's bull and
branch calm promo code then they are
really really comfortable I've never
slept in more comfortable sheets when I
go to hotels the sheets at the hotels
are not nearly as comfortable as the
sheets that you get from bull and branch
calm use that promo code Bennett okay so
president Trump was at the UN this
morning and he gave what was by
virtually all accounts a very good
speech a lot of people on the Left are
very upset cause he was too mean to Iran
in North Korea he was too militant how
dare he be mean to these countries
dianne feinstein sent out a the senator
from california she sent out a note
saying that it was
just terrible how could President Trump
do such a thing
he complained that he greatly escalated
the danger we face from both Iran and
North Korea
she said the goals of the United Nations
are to foster peace and promote global
cooperation today the president used it
as a stage to threaten war he missed an
opportunity to present any positive
action the UN could take with respect to
North Korea and he launched a diatribe
against Iran again offering no pathway
forward okay a couple of things about
this number one the Trump administration
was responsible for a unanimous
resolution in the UN Security Council
levying more sanctions on North Korea
so Trump has done more with the UN on
North Korea than Obama ever did and with
regard to Iran it is the Iran deal that
has allowed the Iranians to gain power
in the region
it's the Iran deal where President Obama
sent literally pallets of cash like tens
of millions of dollars pallets of cash
to the Iranian regime which were then
funneled towards terrorism and gave them
a pathway a legal pathway to a nuclear
weapon in ten years or less and in
Feinstein is ripping Trump over all of
this she's by suggesting he would
revisit and possibly cancel the Iran
nuclear agreement he greatly escalated
the danger we face from both Iran and
North Korea no actually it's the Iran
nuclear agreement that essentially has
made it clear to North Korea that they
should continue to pursue a nuclear
weapon because once you get close enough
to a nuclear weapon then no one will
attack you ever ever ever again what
nation would negotiate with the United
States when the agreements we've reached
with other countries are so easily
undermined we reached a negotiation with
the North Koreans or in the Clinton
administration then Feinstein should
know she was still senator of California
at the time and it didn't make any
difference
they developed a nuclear weapon anyway
so the Democrats are fighting mad and
they've been forced into the awkward
position of now having to defend some of
the worst people on planet earth
so presidents from at the UN today gave
what was a very interventionist speech I
mean people are perpetrating this as a
realist speech but this is not really a
realist speech okay what he was talking
about today he said things like we don't
want to intervene and change other
people's systems for them that's not our
goal but then he talked about Venezuela
and he suggested properly that they need
to return to some sort of democratic
rule in Venezuela well if you're a
hardcore realist like a Rand Paul
realist and a non interventionist you'd
say what does Venezuela have to do with
us okay so they're pressing their own
people okay so that people are stuck
what does that have to do with us the
reality is the vast majority of
Americans as realist as we consider
ourselves still have a moral spine to
what we believe about foreign policy
that doesn't mean we can afford to be
the world's policeman or that we should
intervene everywhere it does mean that
when we see egregious abuses like play
it like in Venezuela that the u.s. does
consider action because the American
people generally demand such action we
generally do a big problem is the
American people don't then have patience
for such action very often but the fact
that we actually care about Venezuela
demonstrates that this is not a hardcore
realist America first administration you
can be America first and still pursue
America's goals because one of our goals
is the fomenting of democracy and and
the liberalism like old-school classical
liberalism around the world again that
doesn't mean military overthrow
sometimes that means sanctions sometimes
that means diplomacy but the idea that
Trump is a non interventionist I think
that didn't survive this speech today so
president Trump starts off by ripping
into Venezuela and talking about
socialism it has been in Venezuela is
pretty spectacular is clip 14 the
problem in Venezuela is not that
socialism has been poorly implemented
but that socialism has been faithfully
implemented okay and you hear total
silence in the room and finally there's
a little bit of applause I like Trump
just staring out at that all the
socialist countries who have been
imbibing this nonsense for a while and
what he says here is exactly right this
is what I have said for a long time it's
not about socialism being a great idea
miss applied it's about a bad idea being
applied properly every place that
socialism is tried to its full capacity
it leads to massive amounts of human
suffering death and starvation so good
for Trump on this Trump also suggested
that the world has a moral
responsibility to side against
aggressors here's President Trump
talking about Iran and saying that the
that we have to confront evil or evil
will triumph if the righteous many do
not confront the wicked few then evil
will try out when decent people and
nations become bystanders to history the
forces of the
structured only gather power and
strength no one has shown more contempt
for other nations and for the well-being
of their own people than the depraved
regime in North Korea
good for him okay what what he's talking
about here is exactly correct this is a
far cry from President Obama who went in
front of the United Nations virtually
every year and then whined about how the
United States was responsible for all
the world's ills he would go up there
and he would talk about how America in
the past had been too braggadocious how
we in the past we've been too
interventionism it's been our fault
we've made people angry we've been too
arrogant
none of that from President Trump good
for President Trump I mean all this is
good that the fact is that we're gonna
need to see some actual hard policy
backing the words you know how far is he
willing to go what is he willing to do
that's always the question right it's
always the sean connery question from
The Untouchables what are you willing to
do that's always the big question in
foreign policy and we don't really have
a clear answer from President Trump on
that but I know one thing he's not
willing to do that is apologize for the
u.s. his presence on the world stage and
that's a very good thing that's very
reassuring because the truth is that in
the past president Trump has made sort
of Ron Paul Ian's comments about about
the role of the United States in the
world you remember just a few months ago
he was talking about how the US has
killed people like Vladimir Putin and
one of the criticisms that I think is
actually not unfair of this speech is
that Trump nowhere in the speech
mentioned Russia and Russia's aggression
continues and I think that's perfectly
appropriate to point out that President
Trump should have mentioned Russia
that's one critique the other critique
of his speech is this line that he
dropped halfway through that is that is
totally trumpian where he's talking
about North Korea and he just decides to
drop an Elton John song in the middle of
his speech about North Korea here's what
he had to say Rocketman is on a suicide
mission for himself and for his regime
Rocketman is on a suicide like he's just
reading straight from this Twitter feed
now I think it's gonna be a long long
time so touchdown brings me round again
man apparently the North Korean
delegation walked out apparently they
were not here for this they said it
allowed a junior diplomat sit-in they
pack their bags last night pre-flight
zero hour 9:00 a.m. so that's yeah I
don't understand what the purpose of the
Rocket Man thing is like it's
it's funny but it's it also undercuts
the seriousness of the situation I mean
imagine I said there's a great tweet
today about this I do love that there's
a there's somebody who tweeted out about
you know Ronald Reagan suggesting that
rhythms were Ronald Reagan should have
gone to Brandenburg Gate and said well
well
birthmark hair tear down this wall might
not have had quite the same effect if he
had said that to a Mikhail Gorbachev so
I'm not sure what the purposes of this
it is funny it is funny the media are
jumping on it and they are suggesting
that this demonstrates that he's not
serious suggesting that he is obviously
stupid and that's why he did all of this
he's Trump and that's why he did all of
this but you know how serious he is
about North Korea what we're gonna find
out what wouldn't find out I don't think
North Korea is gonna stop this sort of
activity
I really don't it is amazing to watch
however the media go completely nuts
over this speech as though he said
something wildly different now here's
the thing that's funny the left is going
crazy over the speech because they're
suggesting that President Obama never
would have been so confrontational he
never would have done anything like this
President Obama launched a virtually
useless and counterproductive war in
Libya President Obama signed off on the
Iran deal President Obama did nothing
about North Korea and he used to go
there and talk consistently about human
rights president Trump doesn't like
talking about human rights very much
when he goes to the UN what he is saying
is more conducive to human rights than
what President Obama said in niceness on
the world stage does not equal the the
promulgation of human rights it doesn't
equal the spread of Human Rights
American strength on the world stage
equals the spread of human rights around
the world doesn't mean we're always
right doesn't mean everything we do is
good doesn't mean every choice you make
is the right one but it does mean that a
stronger America is a freer world in a
weaker America is he is a less free
world and even President Trump who sort
of began this campaign is an anti
interventionist the Iraq war was evil
and conspiratorial all of this he's
moved beyond that now as all presidents
do okay there's a there's a general
foreign policy consensus no matter how
much we wish to bucket Obama was the
first one really to try to bucket who
that says that America needs to be
strong on the world stage because
otherwise the world becomes a worse
place I think Trump understands that and
good for him okay before I go further
there's some big news about Trump and
Paul Manafort and was Trump
right when he tweeted that he was
wiretapped first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at Legacy box so
when was the last time you watched those
old home movies you know the ones that
are stuck in the back of your garage
when's the last time you took out the
films from 1960 that your that your
parents left you and took them out and
actually ran them through a real the
answer is never okay and that's why you
need to take all of those materials and
you need to send them over to my friends
at legacy box right now here's how it
works you load legacy box with your old
tapes film and pictures audio recordings
and you send it back to them and then
you get them back in a couple of weeks
on DVD or thumb drive ready to watch
share and relive legacy box take care of
it takes care of everything they provide
updates at every step of the way they
put a barcode on every piece of material
so you can track it all the way through
the process over a quarter million
families have used them and for a
limited time when you go to legacy box
comm slash Ben you get 40% discount on
your order that's legacy box comm slash
Ben again I think this makes a fantastic
birthday gift it makes a great Mother's
Day or Father's Day gift or Christmas
gift I mean you're really preserving the
most important thing that you and your
parents and your family have which is
your memories because you're not going
to remember all this stuff but once you
have it in material form not only is it
easier to transport than those boxes
that are getting waterlogged in your
garage you'll actually watch them legacy
box comes life ending at a 40% discount
on your order again legacy box comm /
Ben I think is actually really important
service to go check it out legacy box
comm / banner okay so in other news the
the big news last night is that there
were two stories that broke about
president Trump and the Russia
investigation okay so they're the first
big story came courtesy of CNN so CNN
reported Monday evening that
investigators quote wiretapped former
Trump campaign chairman Paul Manafort
under secret orders before and after the
election furthermore according to CNN
manna fort was tapped when he was having
conversations with Trump or may have
been and Manta Ford had a residence at
Trump Tower so it's actually unclear if
the FBI tapped him at that location now
you'll recall that back in January
President Trump tweeted about how the
FBI under Obama had wiretap him at Trump
Tower or E they tapped his wires at
Trump Tower so there's a lot of talk
about how that was a lie it wasn't true
that he wasn't specifically tapped that
his phone wasn't tapped for example so
there are three things that we're
talking about here one is Trump's wires
where Trump's specific wires tapped and
answer seems to be no the second is mana
forts wires yes they were tapped and the
third is were they tapped at Trump Tower
so were their wires tapped at Trump
Tower we don't know the answer to that
there's a fourth question - which is was
Trump on the other end of those calls
okay even if Trump was on the other end
of those calls that doesn't mean that he
was deliberately surveilled it means the
mana fort was surveilled mana forts been
a very dirty player for a very long time
people have known about this for a few
years now that he was basically in bed
with the Putin regime CNN reports the
conversations between mana four and
Trump continued after the president took
office long after the FBI investigation
into mana four was publicly known
sources told CNN they went on into
lawyers for the President and mana for
insisted they stopped according to the
sources it's unclear whether Trump
himself was picked up on the
surveillance so mana 4 was campaign
chair for Trump for about five months he
was not surveilled during that period
after he was ousted from from March to
August after he was ousted the FBI
surveillance began again so it's very
possible the FBI did not tap Trump's
wires but they may have picked Trump up
well tapping mana force where so there
are a couple of questions here - one is
was the fire FISA warrant justified was
this attempt to get Trump and get his
campaign now the case against that is
that mana fort was being tapped before
he was on the Trump campaign and that
while he was on the Trump campaign they
ceased the tap basically and then they
started it up once he was off the Trump
campaign again so that cuts against the
idea that Obama was deliberately
targeting Trump with these wiretaps in
favor of the idea is again Manta fort
was the campaign manager and these taps
continued for a long time and we still
don't know what exactly they were
tapping or how they obtained the FISA
warrant in order to believe that this
was wrong you have to believe that the
FISA Court was basically corrupt that
they granted the warrant in order to go
after Manta fort in order to get Trump
these were a bunch of Obama appointees
doing his bidding in order to sing Trump
if that were the case then you would
imagine that President Obama would have
had a lot at stake in leaking out
information about Manta force wires
being tapped during the election cycle
right I mean that would've been the time
to do it that's not exactly what
happened so I'm a little skeptical of
the claims that this is you know an
Obama setup that he was setting up mana
for it in order to get Trump I'm not
skeptical at all of some of the
unmasking accusations the idea that
Susan Rice was deliberately unmasking
Trump with the hope that that would leak
into the press that I think is quite
possible but I do
by the entirely the argument that Trump
was being wiretapped by evil Obama
forces man afford again is a dirty
player it's very likely he's gonna in a
prosecuted and that's the story from the
New York Times today the New York Times
reported that special investigator
Robert Muller's team has told manna Ford
he will likely face charges according to
the hill quote the warning allegedly a
shock-and-awe tactic came as federal
agents come through his computer files
documents and any other potential pieces
of evidence that could help them in
their federal investigation the New York
Times reported on Monday citing two
people close to the investigation now
one of the things that's interesting
about this is that why would you tell
man apart you're going to indict him
unless you're threatening him with
indictments he got him to flip this is
the most dangerous path for Trump the
most dangerous path for Trump is not
that he was tapped not that he said
anything
egregious tamanna for but that mana for
thinks he knows something and is going
to bargain his way out of trouble by
flipping on Trump this is one of the
reasons why there was a lot of suspicion
when Muller started getting involved
with the ID with the New York Attorney
General State Attorney General Eric
Schneiderman Schneiderman considers
himself part of the anti Trump
resistance he is a far leftist he has
always been a fire leftist and
Schneiderman if he is used as a proxy
for Muller in order to bring state
charges against manna Fort Trump does
not have the power under the
Constitution to pardon man afford for a
state crime and that's a serious problem
for Trump because you could see
Snyderman bringing charges against manna
for mana for flipping against Trump and
all that information getting to Muller
and then you actually have a real
problem on your hands so this looks like
there could be in order for Muller to to
retain his patina of objectivity he's
gonna need to ask Schneiderman to step
aside if you really believe state crimes
have been have been committed here
Sneiderman cannot be the face of the
people going after mana for it's just
it's too political it's a disaster if
you think that Jeff Sessions was right
to recuse himself I think he probably
was then you also have to believe that
Schneiderman should recuse himself in
this invest investigation into Manta
Ford because he's just too politically
driven he's just too politically driven
okay all of the reason that I go into
all of this is because it's so easy to
look and see these bizarre sort of
parallel universes that the right and
the left live in so the left is looking
at this story and they're saying AHA
mana fort was tapped because mana Ford
is guilty and that means Trump is guilty
no evidence that Trump is guilty
no buttons the Trump was even caught on
the tapes no buttons Veni of that I've
said for well over a year at this point
that mana fort was a bad pick by Trump
I'd said for months that if anyone was
gonna get incited from the Trump
campaign it was going to be mana fort
not Trump again mana fork could have
been working with the Russians and not
sold Trump that's quite plausible mana
forts work with the Russians for years
and why would he tell Trump Trump's a
big mouth
Trump and go blow that thing wide open
so it's quite possible that mana fort is
guilty and Trump isn't and for the
people on the right who are saying this
justifies Trump's tweets about
wiretapping okay first of all I'm I
really don't I'm not sure that it does I
don't think that it does but beyond that
I think that it is I think it is
important to recognize that that's not a
good story for you if you're a trump
supporter if your defense is Trump was
right about the tapping he was so right
that they were tapping his line because
they suspected Madoff Lord of a crime
and sir Trump's probably involved in a
crime I'm not sure that's a good line of
defense for you I mean you can celebrate
him being right about the tweet and then
get him deep more deeply involved in the
Manta fort investigation that doesn't
seem brilliant
that doesn't seem great I just don't see
the the upside there for President Trump
so that's the story with all this again
I think that well it's being blown up
into a headline on CNN I don't think
this is actually huge news and while
it's being blown up by people on the
right to say Trump was right all along
this whole shtick of Trump was right all
along about a tweet that doesn't matter
seems to me counterproductive because
the only thing that matters here is
whether there's going to be any
underlying crime that's found not
whether Trump was right about the tweet
unless again you believe that that Obama
was deliberately targeting members of
the Trump team in order to bring him
down and I do have some questions about
that believe me I'm more than happy to
talk about President Trump misusing the
levers of government I wrote an entire
book about it it's called the people
versus Barack Obama in which I suggested
that the Obama administration engaged in
criminal activity in things like the IRS
scandal but I want to see the evidence
that President Obama did something
wildly improper in targeting Paul
Manafort
or the FISA Court did something wildly
improper in issuing the FISA warrant
before I jump down Obama's throat and
suggest that this was all targeted
attempt to get Trump I'm not sure that I
see that here okay so before I go any
further and explain the latest news on
Obamacare appeal I
the Democrats completely falling apart
by the way I mean I need to show you
some footage of Nancy Pelosi being
yelled at by her own side which is just
incredible before I do any of that first
I want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at stamps.com okay so you're sick
of waiting in line at the post office I
know you are because I hate waiting in
line at the post office it's a waste of
time and there are only so many times
you can refresh Twitter while waiting in
line at the post office
well you no longer have to do that go
over to stamps.com and they bring you
all the services of the US Postal
Service right to your fingertips you can
buy and print US postage for any letter
any package any class of mail using your
own computer and print so you can print
it directly onto an envelope you can
print it directly onto a piece of paper
and tape it to an envelope
you can print it onto stickers which act
as stamps okay they will even send you a
digital scale automatically calculating
an exact postage and help you decide the
best class of mail based on your needs
so you don't even have to lease an
expensive postage meter use stamps calm
right now n if you sign up at stamps
calm they have a special offer that
includes a four week trap plus postage
and a digital scale without long term
commitments and that's what you get if
you type Shapiro's into the into the
promo code that's there's a microphone
at the top of the page and you type
Shapiro in there go to Sam's comm and
for promo code Shapiro and right now my
listeners can get that four-week trial
plus postage and digital scale without
any long-term commitments as a pretty
solid deal never go to the post office
again and save yourself tons of time be
more accurate with your postage stamps
comm and her promo code Shapiro to take
advantage of that okay so in other news
before September 30th the Republicans
now have about a week and a half to pass
Obamacare appeal if they do not pass
Obamacare appeal in a week and a half
they're not getting it done this year if
they don't get it done this year it's
very likely that it's very unlikely
they're gonna get it done next year the
reason being once we hit a midterm
election year everyone is really antsy
no one wants to be seen as voting for
something super controversial so the
latest version of Obamacare quasi repeal
it's not full repeal because the only
way to do full repeal presumably would
be to would would be to get 60 votes in
the Senate or two or to get the Senate
parliamentarian to rule that a majority
can overthrow regulations right now that
so here's how it works in the Senate
there's a weird rule called
reconciliation in the Senate
reconciliation means
that the Senate can vote with 51 votes
they don't need 60 votes they need 51
votes he can't filibuster it to alter
American law in a way that is budget
neutral that does not increase the
budget and that affects standing
versions of American law so that means
that getting rid of regulations it's
kind of difficult to determine how
that's going to impact the budget and so
getting rid of regulations purely the
general rule according to the Senate
parliamentarian is the DAT doesn't fall
under reconciliation you need 60 votes
this is why Obama needed 60 votes for
Obamacare because he was creating new
law it wasn't just getting rid of old
law he's creating new law okay so here's
the new version that's being rolled out
it's being rolled out by senators
Lindsey Graham and Bill Cassidy it is a
much better version of what we saw
before it is a better version of what we
saw before so here we're gonna go
through it briefly here so you know what
it is
yeah I've been talking with several of
the Senators and it seems like there's
some good momentum behind this
particular bill it's not a full repeal
of Obamacare it doesn't get rid of all
of Obama cares taxes it doesn't get rid
of all of Obama cares regulations at the
federal level it doesn't get rid of the
regulations it does allow state waivers
and those state waivers could
theoretically create the the incentive
for states to move toward loosening
regulations but it does not get rid of
the Obamacare regulations at the federal
level its advocates say it's Federalists
that it evolves power to the states
people like Rand Paul say it doesn't do
enough so here's what's in it first of
all Medicaid gets slashed so one of the
big problems with Obamacare is that it
has this open-ended commitment to
increase Medicaid exposure by the
federal government we're gonna pay for
your Medicaid expansion basically ad
infinitum on an as-needed basis well
this bill the Cassidy Graham bill it
slashes Medicaid growth pretty
dramatically instead of the federal
government sending money to States on a
need basis states are instead given
block grants which means that we just
send them a set amount of money it's not
based on need and all the money in these
block grants instead of going to the
states that have already expanded their
Medicaid rolls as Obamacare did right
that was the incentive Obama said you
want you want this money you need to
increase your your Obama care exchange
need to create an Obama care exchange
then we'll send you money this new bill
gets rid of that provision it basically
says they we're going to allocate to all
the states evenly rather than two states
that expanded their Obama there Obama
care or subsidized Medicaid rolls so
that means that states like Texas
benefit states like California would
lose the goal would be it would be to
cut expected Medicaid funding on the
federal level by one-third by 2026 and
eliminating it entirely by 2027 now the
problem with this of course is that
really kicks the can down the road if
you think Congress is going to eliminate
the subsidies you have another thing
coming
Congress has never heavily limited
medical subsidies okay as I say Medicaid
is redistributed the state's hearted hit
hardest hit are the ones that have
already expanded their Medicaid rolls
based on Obamacare is false and and
lying expansion of regulations around
the actual law it does get rid of the
individual mandate so you no longer have
to buy health insurance this does drive
up prices right remember the individual
mandate is a funding mechanism for
redistributed of health care the
Obamacare mandate forces me as a healthy
person to pay for my health care so that
an old sick person can pay less for
theirs that's what Obamacare individual
mandate does so how do they fill in that
gap for the insurance companies well
what they do is they allow states to
waive essential benefits okay so this
sort of halfway brings back the the
state the the ability for insurance
companies to sell plans that do not
include pre-existing conditions so
that's how the that's how they are going
to bring down the cost is by allowing
more competition in the marketplace by
allowing them to sell different types of
different types of insurance so relieve
some of the regulations now getting rid
of the pre-existing conditions plans
brings down the overall cost of health
insurance but for a select few people
who are already sick and don't get
insurance through their employer those
people are going to see increased health
care cost they well they'll see
increased healthcare costs there's an
increase in subsidies to try and make up
for that the question is whether that is
enough so this is a better bill than the
one that Republicans rejected a couple
of months back it still won't do enough
to open up competition because it leaves
a lot of these key regulations in place
until all pre-existing conditions on
regulations are removed you're gonna see
prices increase because competition
won't be free and open it doesn't get
rid of all of Obamacare taxes either but
it is a step in the right direction I
think there's a good shot that it passes
and it should it should pass this is a
bill that I think is actually worth
voting for as long as we don't say that
this is all right this is not the end of
the story this is the first step toward
Obamacare repeal this is not the
entirety of Obamacare repeal
and so it's deeply important that we
make that distinction because we don't
want to lie to constituents who expect
that this is gonna fix everything okay
meanwhile while Republicans are
struggling over the Russia investigation
and Obamacare appeal there is there's
something else happening among the
Democrats and that is a full-scale
disaster so Democrats you know there's
this idea that when you're in the
opposition that you're unified and
you're cohesive and you have the ability
to push things and president Trump
lately has been giving up the Democrats
pretty easily
well the Democrats have some problems of
their own this was demonstrated last
night when a bunch of illegal immigrant
protesters descended on a Nancy Pelosi
press conference here's what it looked
like since you don't want to listen
since you don't want to listen we'll
have to just go
[Applause]
Nancy Pelosi is too far right for them
they're protesting daca because they say
it doesn't do enough they want to get
they were protesting because they want
ice to be completely disbanded they want
a completely open border this is the
Democrat base or at least part of the
Democrat base and they don't know what
to do about it they don't know what to
do about it it's completely and utterly
bereft of reason it's totally amazing
and the Democrats are moving further and
further to the left in order to take
advantage of these people but in doing
so they're leaving the middle like
senator Kirsten Gillibrand she's
considered a 2020 contender and she came
out and she said that who are the
leaders of our party Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren my god I think you have
your congressional leaders of course but
I think you know senator Sanders is out
there talking about things that has big
ideas like Medicare for all I think
Elizabeth Warren's out there talking
about a rigged system that we
desperately need to fix for working
family okay amazing that this is their
new party their new party is is
Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders good
luck with that gang I mean they're so
radical that luis gutierrez the
representative he was ripping on john
kelly oh but who is trumps chief of
staff he said that john kelly was
basically a traitor to the united states
despite his military service and said
that he had he had basically sold out
americans and all this and gutierrez
refuses to apologize because that's how
polarize you have to be to demonstrate
to your base that you're crazy enough to
represent them do you regret speaking
that strongly and criticizing john kelly
let me just say this i could have been
more careful but with the use of my
words and there are times that you need
to reevaluate having said that i saw him
as head of Homeland Security the poor
grandmother's who had been for 15 years
reporting dutifully to Homeland Security
with their American citizen
grandchildren heartless actions and
increasing deportation against people
who know who presented no threat so in
other words no apology to Senator to
general Kelly for basically calling him
a sellout to the United States of
America that is the new Democratic Party
they've got some serious problems and
meanwhile they still have Hillary
trolling around for book money trying to
claim that she's gonna challenge the
legitimacy of the election I'm old
enough to remember when it was crazy
when President Trump said that he might
challenge the legitimacy of the election
in fact
sized him for here was president Trump
then candidate Trump saying that he
might challenge the legitimacy of the
election way back when in October M a
victim of one of the great political
smear campaigns in the history of our
country
they are coming after me to try and
destroy what is considered by even them
the greatest movement in the history of
our country there's never been anything
ok so then there was Trump back in
October and the media went nuts over
this he was asked about it in debates
Hillary said it was despicable for
anybody to challenge the results of an
election here is Hillary Clinton
yesterday talking about challenging the
legitimacy of the election eight months
after it took place would you completely
rule out questioning the legitimacy of
this election if we learn that the
Russian interference in the election is
even deeper than we know now
no I would not I would say you're not
gonna rule it no I wouldn't rule it out
but I also what are the means like
totally unprecedented in every way it is
what would be the means to challenge it
if you thought it should be challenged
basically I don't believe there are
there are scholars academics who have
arguments that it would be but I don't I
don't think they're on strong ground I
mean amazing so this is the new
democratic party Hillary Clinton whining
about her life and Bernie Sanders and
Kristin Gillibrand illegal immigrants
outing and Nancy Pelosi for not being
crazy enough so while we talk about the
Republican Party having some problems
the Democrats are far worse off than the
Republicans right now ok so before I get
to things I like and things I hate I
first want to say thank you to our
sponsors over $1 shave club so everyone
knows Dollar Shave Club ships terrific
razors for a few bucks I've been a
member for a while and I really enjoy
the shape particularly under the jawline
for the Orthodox Jews we got to use a
straightedge under the draw line only
but they have other things too they body
wash shampoo hair gel lip balm
everything I mean everything that you
need for your bathroom you can get at
Dollar Shave Club there's a lot of
fantastic stuff there and it comes
directly to you if you are sick of the
nonsense at the store trying to pick out
what's the best product you just want
everything to come in a box right now
Dollar Shave Club is basically giving
away their starter set to new members
for only 5 bucks this starter set
features their executive razor and three
trial sized versions of the most popular
products that help you stay clean and
fresh so in the first box you receive
their shea butter their body wash and
their one wipe Charlies butt wipes yes
indeed you also receive their executive
razor which includes their premium
weighty handle and full consent of
cartridges and after the
but after the first box replacement
cartridges are sent for only a few bucks
a month so that means that you're
constantly being replenished in these
great resources the shea butter is
really terrific I particularly like the
body wash as well the razors are
excellent and you never have to go to
the store again and over spend for
razors that that cost you a bajillion
dollars and wait in line and first you
have to shave for two days with a rusty
razor before you're reminded that you
ought to replace your blade Dollar Shave
club's high quality products have you
cover from top to bottom
literally and right now I'll go to
dollarshaveclub.com slash pen that is
dollarshaveclub.com slash been there is
no better time to try the club and I
promise you that it is again it's one of
these things that's gonna make your life
better in ways they had not thought
possible from top to bottom Dollar Shave
Club calm then use that slash Bend
dollarshaveclub.com slash pen lets them
know that we sent you and as I say you
also right now get their starter set for
five bucks which is basically a giveaway
and and then after that you receive it
on a monthly basis so super cool Dollar
Shave Club and we appreciate their
sponsorship so use that slash pens that
they know that we sent you okay so I
have some pretty epic things I like in
things I hate today
but for that you're gonna have to go
over see daily wire comm and subscribe
so $9.99 a month get to a subscription
to daily wire comm that means you got
this show it means that today
today is the big day you're going to get
to participate in our Q&A so we're gonna
doing a Q&A a little bit later this
afternoon you get to ask us questions
directly to to this afternoon Pacific
time you get to ask us questions
directly and I will answer every
question that you have had in your head
all your lives will be made
significantly better by this you get
$4.99 a month you get access to that if
you don't subscribe you don't get to ask
questions and I guess you're left in the
outer darkness but you also get Michael
Knowles's show which begins in 45
minutes here you'd andrew Clavin show
which or sorry Andrew Clavin shown in 45
minutes michael Knowles's show at 12:30
p.m. Pacific time and right now for $99
a year all of the aforementioned things
plus you get this leftist here's how to
cold mug tumblr the greatest of all
beverage vessels it is incredible in
every conceivable way I don't need to
belabor the point as I seem to every day
it is great okay so you get all of those
things for $99 a year or if you just
want to listen later go over to iTunes
or SoundCloud we are the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay time for some things I like and
then some things that I hate so things
that I like I figured that since I did
Rebecca yesterday the book by Daphne du
Maurier and the movie with Laurence
Olivier we'll do some Laurence Olivier
Gothic stuff and so this is Laurence
Olivier in Wuthering Heights this has
one of the great scores of all time it's
sort of a forgotten classic weathering
Heights once maskers in 1939 it's it's
really a terrific film old-school kind
of glorious if it'd have been color
you'd say that it was in glorious color
but really is in glorious black and
white it's really terrific merle oberon
Laurence Olivier very very young David
Niven it's it's a terrific film the book
is also quite good obviously and you
should check it out here's a little bit
of the trailer
[Music]
don't you see what he's been doing he's
been using you to be near me to smile
with me behind your back to try to roll
something in my heart that's dead you
can't if it's not a man but something
dark and horrible to live with your mobs
own capsule but I don't know why you're
acting so because you love him Oh
Heathcliff you must not do this
villainous thing she hasn't harmed you
you haven't punished me I'm going to
when I take it in my arms when I kiss
her when I promised her life and
happiness Oh Heathcliff if there's
anything human left in you don't do this
oh why won't you let me come near you
I'm not black and horrible they will
think I'm full of pain I can make you
happy
let me try he's a very dark character
obviously the Laurence Olivier character
and it is very romantic it's great it's
the score is is really terrific I'm
trying to remember who wrote the Scott
Alfred Newman of course yeah the great
Alfred Newman and one of the great film
scores of all time go and check it out
tonight it's a it's a great date movie
and you'll think of what your parents
this date movie was like because when it
came out okay other things that I like
so I think that it is amazing that the
the media are still going nuts over Sean
Spicer so last night I was on CNN with
Don Lemon and Don was upset with Sean
Spicer appearing at the Emmys oh how
dare the Emmys go easy on Sean Spicer
they should have taken him out there and
beaten him with sticks they should have
taken him out there and they should have
poured a bucket of pig's blood on his
head just like Harry that's what it
should have been CNN they had a
commentator who said the Emmy in that
the Emmys honoring Sean Spicer it was
just terrible how could they this is
White House reporter Caitlin Collins the
CNN White House reporter objective
journalism at its finest so there were
some laughter there was some awkwardness
what do you think I find it humorous at
all us someone who sat in that press
briefing room every day that Sean Spicer
was the press secretary I just don't
think it's humorous when the former
White House spokesman comes out at this
awards show with all these Holly ways
that they often rail against to make fun
of the fact and you know pretty much
emitted
he lied to the American people while he
was being paid by the American people to
be a spokesman for the White House this
is someone who when he came out a few
days after that inauguration statement
he promised not to lie and to tell the
self-righteousness here that I that I
kind of enjoy its the idea from the
media and from Hollywood that we are the
arbiters of truth the grading grand
arbiters of truth the people who had no
problem with Michelle Obama at the
Oscars in 2013 or Joe Biden at the
Oscars in 2016 who did a legitimate
sitcom Hollywood did a legitimate sitcom
with a guy named John Lovett who's now
over at pod save America
he was an Obama staffer okay the Obama
administration was chock-full of untruth
for years but nobody seemed to object
Sean Spicer the reason that everybody is
laughing at Sean Spicer is not because
Sean Spicer was a liar okay we're used
to that from our politicians it's
because Sean Spicer was uniquely
horrible at lying that's why we all
think it was funny okay he was really
terrible at it like Sean Spicer there's
a part deep down inside Sean Spicer that
when you watch him you know there's a
part of him that cringes when he lies
that's why you can see the deadness in
his eyes when he was lying about crowd
sighs and so when he did that the other
night like that was actually a blow in
favor of truth because now I guess we
were all moving beyond the idea that he
wasn't fibbing I don't understand why
that's a terrible thing and why
Hollywood is gonna get in the media are
gonna get so upset about this oh god
he's how could Hollywood honor such a
man they were honoring him he was the
punch line of the joke
he was the punch line I mean they were
laughing at him they weren't laughing
with him the whole thing is just very
silly okay time for a couple of things
that I hate so
there's an astonishing poll out today
from Brookings Institute it is
unbelievable okay the poll is about
whether or not speakers like me should
be shut down on college campuses okay
here's the question a public university
invites a very controversial speaker to
an on-campus event the speaker is known
for making offensive and hurtful
statements a student group opposed to
the speaker disrupts the speech by
loudly and repeatedly shouting so the
audience cannot hear the speaker do you
agree or disagree that the student
groups actions are acceptable Democrats
62% agree sixty-two percent six in ten
Democrats Republicans sixty-one percent
disagree independents 55 percent
disagree males particularly agree with
the statement that it's okay to shout
down speakers so it's okay to just go
and shout them down okay this is even
more others even worsse
a public university invites a
controversial speaker to an on-campus
event a student opposed to the speaker
uses violence to prevent the speaker
from speaking is this okay is this okay
twenty percent of Democrats agree
twenty-two percent of Republicans agree
that it is okay to use violence to shut
down speakers on the other side one in
five Americans believe this totally
insane totally insane okay this is
unamerican it's unamerican and you see
this unfortunately pervading the highest
levels of the of the left intelligencia
i'm shocked by that republican statistic
by the way the twenty two percent of
republicans are okay with violence
shutting down a speech that's an amazing
thing but a Princeton professor was
legitimately on TV there's a couple days
ago opposing my appearance at Berkeley
for some of these same reasons do you
think it's productive for people to
interrupt the conservative speaker to
walk up on the stage to block his
ability to the point where that person
has to be let out by security no not
that doesn't but in some instances I
think there are moments where I don't
feel it necessary for me to have to
endure an argument that questions my
presence okay okay just amazing just
incredibly amazing that they're actual
intellects who suggest that it's okay to
shut down speeches on these grounds so
amazing stuff okay
time for a quick deconstruction of the
culture so I
one of the things that happened at the
Emmys the other night that I didn't have
a chance to comment on is there's an
actress named Issa Rae I'm not sure what
show she's on I guess that she's on
insecure she's the creator and star of
HBO's insecure and she was very candid
about who she wanted to win here's what
she had to say who are you rooting for
tonight okay so imagine a white person
said that I'm rooting for everyone white
and imagine an Asian person said I'm
rooting for everyone Asian this notion
of racial solidarity I'm rooting for
everyone black and we're supposed to
pretend that's not racism of course is
racism why wouldn't you root for the
best person why don't you say I root for
my friends why wouldn't you say I root
for the people who even have the same
political beliefs that I do right why
does it have to be based on race by the
way I don't think that that's true I
think that if they're a documentary
about Clarence Thomas and Clarence
Thomas were up for an Emmy for some rod
reason that she would not be rooting for
Clarence Thomas to win I think what she
does is she like a lot of people on the
Left identifies her own politics with
blackness and then suggests that
blackness is a reason why people should
win Emmys pretty gross okay she said
that she was pleased with the number of
people of color who are nominated this
year quote you have so many people
behind the camera and behind the scenes
committed to telling authentic real
stories that haven't been seen on
television before and your body ins is
embracing it because they're tired of
seeing the same old same old stories so
it's a pleasure to be among such great
company again I don't understand what
the color has anything to do with it the
quality of the stories is fine why
didn't you just say that why don't you
just say all the people who write great
stories that haven't been told before
I'm eager to see those people win but
the focus on color ruins the country
it ruins the country whether it's coming
from white people or black people and
pretending that it is only a problem
when it comes from one race is just
absurd it's absurd it's silly it's
backward and it is indeed racist it's
amazing how people get away with this in
the cultural world in a way they never
would be able to in the political world
kind of astonishing but I'm the threat
to American civility when I speak on
campus and say we should judge people
individually I'm the threat to American
civility but Issa Rae is the is the
person who stands up for the great
tradition of diversity by saying that
she's rooting for all the black people
pretty incredible well we'll be back
here tomorrow I want to give you a
further breakdown of president from C UN
speech plus as always the news of the
day I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]